un souci cette semaine l'abattoir et m
pas de steak au menu chez cette
habitante du lamentin sur le marché de
la commune les étals sont désespérément
vides
de nombreux bouchers se sont laissés
surprendre par l'arrêt de l'activité à
l'abattoir ne sommes pas indemnisé rien
du tout nous attendons la reprise lundi
prochain mais c'est vrai que nous sommes
tous des pères et mères de famille nous
avons une entrée d'école qui arrivent
nous avons l'aider parce qu'ils ont dû
penser à tout cela
au lieu de dire qu'on ferme pour faire
je suis d'accord là pour la fermeture je
suis d'accord qu'il ya des trucs à faire
mais passer aux professionnels parce que
nous sommes des artisans bouchers les
coopératives nous sommes tous au chômage
mais pour les responsables de la
structure cette suspension était
indispensable afin d'effectuer des
ajustements sur les chaînes d'abattage
ainsi que la mise à jour de l'ensemble
du système informatique
boucher et coopérative avait été prévenu
par e-mail vendredi dernier tout le
personnel tous les usagers ont été
avertis de cette fermeture
néanmoins il y à des utilisateurs de
l'abattoir qui s'opposait la mission de
la cimade qui sont au courant et
problème
on avait pour pouvoir effectuer tous ces
dossiers tous et logistique à mettre en
place le système doit impérativement
être opérationnel au 1er septembre
il devrait permettre d'éviter un nouveau
naufrage financier à l'abattoir là c'est
mam liquidée il ya quelques mois avait
accumulé plus d'un million deux cent
mille euros de déficit
les trois quarts de cette somme
correspondant à des factures impayées
par les éleveurs et les coopératives de
boucher